8 news now breaking news alert
thank you for joining us here at noon
i'm john langler and again we do start
with that breaking news streets closed
after a deadly car crash in the
southwest valley metro and clark county
school district police are now
investigating this happened near
windmill in torrey pines just before 9
bianca holmen live at the scene with the
latest details bianca good afternoon
good afternoon so there is still a
police presence here at windmill in
torrey pines and so
again just past this yellow tape there
is debris still in the road and just
past yellow tape you can see the two
cars that were involved it was a red
sedan and also a dark colored van that
was involved in the crash
and also there is a middle school that
is nearby it's canarelli middle school
so that is could be why that ccsd
responded to
this situation so
as the investigation went on metro
actually took over the investigation so
once we learn more details we will keep
you updated online and on air but this
area will remain closed as they continue
the investigation bianca holman live
local now